Kvala kububaruhl inni thriller wakkel ikk thrill
innom parafånds
eller artemars thandrengeløke paly agathir ina slanger-mannila
a a a arturkulu urippener
w pappa raiuh velkurti ullar Pudringer India
når Du Seriøst TikTok TikTok suddenly someone come and say wow,
this guy is doing wrong.
Isn't that then the writer they used to include the honesty.
So we are always in right track.
We talk about the Tamil school every year we are giving 5 million
started from 2008 2000000+
now 35 million next year could be more than that depends of our income.
Temples they are giving 1.2 million.
Tamil school, Tambamba School I started from few students.
Now we are we already given the 323,000 or something
but that day I gave it 324 students.
First student we give 300 rand cash.
This is my annual program.
Some claims that they are saying wow,
because of the election and this guy come and do the drama
so they chose that they lack of information or idea or knowledge
that's very wrong. We are giving the can getting government
we are helping the post.
We are also selecting very you know uh uh the technical panel.
We are looking for really poor children
because we already got a limited funds on that
so join the ring gate.
We are spending about more than a million ring gate for that program
and then this IPD program
we are giving one of 5,000 ring gate for the dignity holders
and then for diploma we are Giving you 303,000 something.
These are the initiative you can join the landmembers Ghana the timer
by beginning of the first 10 years,
you will settle more than 200 temples land.
It's a break record breaking,
you know, human already
sorry to tell you that compared to better the past 10 years,
more than 200 temples already gathered with the land
anoreo-en wakkel kvala kububarwin
adopta tannen urippner tørrhenskje Kvala Kububarub Pakatan Harapanin
PLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLINLIN.
Kita Perlu Mengalahkan Semua Komuniti untuk Memandang Serius Berkenan
Pilihan Raya Kecil KKB ini bahkan Semua Orang Keluar.
Undi kenapa, kita perlu Mengalahkan Semua Orang Keluar.
Undi kerana saya rasa
undi tu adalah hak kita sebagai seorang AA Warga Malaysia.
Kita NAK tentukan Masa depan kita,
kita Bukan NAK lawan ISU Perkauman.
Kita NAK elakkan ISU Perkauman.
Kerana itu saya rasa Bukan seperti apa Yang YBC.
Kata tadi ini Bukan Merupakan satu healthy Tren.
Kalau Kita selalu NAK sentuh ISU Perkauman
Topik Perkauman Bila Kita NAK Keluar Daripada ISU Perkauman Malaysia.
We should move forward. We should rise again in Malaysia.
Daddy, if we want to rise again,
especially from the economy point of view,
Selangor has to move. We have to run.
We have to run in order to lead other state to move together.
By doing so, I think we can make meridians rise again.
Kvala kububar uvakaløtel anevaro tentkartesm vekkel uvakaløtel,
uvakaløp, uvakaløp,
uvakkaløp, uvak
tjueen-tjueen-tjueen-tjueen-tjueen-tjueen-tjueen-tjueen-tjueen-tjueen-tjueen
aabrini er på trilmaid på tre tre tamal uda tangel Oden an Sandibel
Tamar Thai Thai Thai Thai Thai Thai Thai Thai.
Haha.